hello and welcome to this video playing
FM Marco it's not you more later yep so
M yeah he always plays coming porn stuff
yeah Bishop f4 Bishop g5 things like
that it's a little bit different a
little bit difficult to get something
really interesting going but that this
is bad for why do anything I'm just
saying to ok actually closes the
position for something known each type
of game okay so if i go g5 and d5 is
that too aggressive maybe it is but i
want to get something going in might be
to lose but ok we'll see what happens
he's secure on a counter attacking
player I mean but he's really okay at
that it doesn't do much on his own
accord this is on account whatever yeah
I think you get my drift he rather lets
the other guy do something and then sees
that he can counter-attack okay so here
is this may be possible his queen is
always on my rook here maybe I can
irritate him but that a little bit my
queen is of course also opposed to the
rook okay Queen f1 this is idn quite
clearly so let's move the Queen here out
of the way and potentially attack be too
okay a couple of things going on here
not sure what he's supposed to do if i
take it I don't want to do that and want
to release the tension here takes Queen
takes and not show d5 hangs b2 is
hanging but i rather I'm not sure that I
want to take them I was mostly playing
Queen B 6 to get all of the default he
seems concerned about it
yeah if i take here I'll take I can take
you through your eyes or Bishop g6 is
also interesting in Queen d3 I think
taking years I'm making quite some sense
yeah thinkable I know what exactly what
white would probably sacrifice some kind
of material now Bishop h7 set it off
takes Queen d3 check but I can move the
King 2 h8 for example yeah check I can
go to an ATM and now are lots of stuff
is hanging in particular this route okay
so I'll take the rook now okay so if i
take f3 has to take there twice e 1 is
hanging I cannot resist a key one night
takes something is there something there
Queen before something this Bishop is
strange if I play night before okay come
on I'll take this now and don't want to
spend ages him centralized and now what
is happening here night before maybe
let's do this maybe it's got Queen 27 or
something no they have Queen sex okay
that's not happening the queen is
hanging okay he just goes back I was
thinking Bishop g6 in this case just
trade stuff come on let's
let's do this straight stuff keep this
check
93 is probably helpful
ok so maybe here check
see if i can get a counter check going
here somehow ok ok it's not threatening
to take because queen you five wins
I think you in you five still chance ok
I didn't see that move I could mean of
aid or something hmm
time morning check yeah this is more
difficult than it should have been my
king position is just a bit shaky
and noting to take this not quite sure
why I did this to be perfectly honest
and then queen of four here
I just got this bloody chick on these
six again or be sex for that matter I no
no check in check okay white forfeits
I'm tired I didn't even pay attention to
the time I know what I don't know is it
winning probably it should be because of
my advanced f corner I can just and I
can just enter yeah oh it's toughest
he's kind of a very solid player I think
I mean I played the technical part of it
now I know weird way but I think this
was okay I mean here I'm objectively
just winning check and probably I missed
some stuff here Jack I think I'm okay up
to this point cruelty age yeah after
this the engine wants to ah this is a
very very interesting move the idea is
to like him I can get this damn ticks
ticks and I'll take him okay so we had
this yeah it should be it should be
winning of course but it is still yeah
maybe it was a bad idea to weaken my
position even more his King is a little
bit safe I'm who k2 seems to be Pam
check check yeah no I dropped some stuff
them yeah tough game I've wanted at the
end but it was was them not at all
clearly at the end okay well thanks for
watching